NOW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE
ON THAT LATER IN THE SHOW.
WE FIRST GET BACK TO OUR TOP
STORY AS WE ARE JOINED BY
NORTH CAROLINA CONGRESSMAN
MARK MEADOWS.
OHIO CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN,
BOTH LEADERS OF THE FREEDOM
CAUCUS.
ALL RIGHT.
JIM, I WILL START WITH YOU
TONIGHT.
>> SURE.
>> Sean: THIS IS WHAT WE
GET.
>> YEP.
>> Sean: A MAN'S LIFE
RUINED.
ALL OF THESE OTHER PEOPLE
HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES THAT
WE KNOW OF.
THE INFORMATION OBTAINED ON
GENERAL FLYNN WAS OBTAINED
ILLEGALLY.
>> YEP.
>> Sean: THEY PUT HIS FAMILY
THROUGH HELL.
HE HAS TO SELL HIS HOUSE.
THEY THREATEN HIS FAMILY OR
HE FALLS ON THE SWORD AND
SIGNS SOMETHING HE KNOWS IS
NOT TRUE SO THEY DON'T GO
AFTER HIS FAMILY.
IS THAT JUSTICE IN AMERICA?
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
AND YOUR MODERN LOG WAS
RIGHT ON TARGET, SEAN.
REMEMBER, JAMES COMEY,
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI FIRED
DEPUTY DIRECTOR MCCABE LIED
THREE TIMES UNDER OATH
FIRED.
CHIEF COUNSEL AT THE FBI
DEMOTED AND THEN LEFT.
LISA PAGE DEMOTED AND LEFT.
DEPUTY HEAD OF
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE PETER
STRZOK DEMOTED AND THEN
FIRED.
BUT EVEN THOSE FIVE PEOPLE
THOUGHT MIKE FLYNN DIDN'T
LIE WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWED
BY THE FBI.
ONLY BOB MUELLER DID AND NOW
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
WE HAVE GOT TO KEEP THIS IN
CONTEXT.
THE TOP PEOPLE AT THE FBI
ALL DEMOTED, LEFT, OR FIRED
WHO HAVE LAUNCHED AND RAN
THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
LAUNCHED AND RAN THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
PUT THE FAKE DOSSIER IN
FRONT OF THE FISA COURT TO
GET A WARRANT TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
EVEN THEY DIDN'T THINK MIKE
FLYNN LIED WHEN HE WAS BEING
INTERVIEWED BY THE FBI.
BOB MUELLER IS SAYING HE
SHOULD GET THE MOST LENIENT
SENTENCE POSSIBLE BUT THEY
STILL HAVE THE INFORMATION
THEY GAVE HIM.
WE WILL FIND OUT WHAT THAT
IS WHEN WE GET THE
UNREDACTED VERSION OF WHAT
REFERRING TO TONIGHT.
>> I'M LOOKING MARK MEADOWS
THROUGH ALL OF THIS HERE
"THE WASHINGTON POST"
PUBLISHED A STORY.
RUSSIA'S AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED STATES ON
DECEMBER 29TH, WOULDN'T IT
BE A NORMAL PROCESS FOR AN
INCOMING DIRECTOR SUCH AS
GENERAL FLYNN TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH A SOON TO
BE COUNTERPARTS ABOUT
IMPORTANT ISSUES, EVEN A
CHANGE OF POLICY THAT MIGHT
BE COMING OR DIFFERENT
POINTS OF VIEW THAT THEY MAY
HAVE CONSIDERING WE HAVE
DIAMETRICALLY OPPOSED VIEWS
BETWEEN OBAMA AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP?
>> WELL, IT WOULD BE A
NATURAL OCCURRENCE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THERE ARE
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ON
THE HILL THAT PROBABLY HAVE
HAD A LOT MORE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR
THAN MIKE FLYNN EVER THOUGHT
ABOUT HAVING.
AND, YET, HERE WE ARE
TONIGHT LOOKING AT A THREE
STAR GENERAL BEING HELD
GUILTY FOR MISSING A DAY AND
PERHAPS NOT RECALLING
SOMETHING.
BUT HERE'S THE OTHER THING
THAT WE HAVE GOT TO
REMEMBER, SEAN, IS.
THIS I HAVE LOOKED AT THIS
REPORT AND, YES, EVERYBODY
IS GOING TO FOCUS ON WHAT
HAS BEEN REDACTED.
LET'S LOOK AT WHAT IS NOT IN
THERE.
THERE IS NO SUGGESTION THAT
MICHAEL FLYNN HAD ANYTHING
TO DO WITH COLLUSION.
HE WAS WITH THE TRANSITION
TEAM.
HE WAS PART OF THE CAMPAIGN.
AND, YET, THERE IS NO
MENTION OF COLLUSION.
I THINK IT'S GOOD NEWS FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TONIGHT THAT
THIS IS WHAT HAS COME DOWN
TO, EVEN THOUGH THEY SAID HE
SUBSTANTIALLY COOPERATED, I
THINK HE SUBSTANTIALLY
COOPERATED TO SAY THAT THERE
WAS NO COLLUSION AND WE CAN
LOOK AT IT WITH THAT IN
MIND.
>> Sean: JIM JORDAN I WILL
READ TO YOU THE POST WHETHER
THE ACTIONS VIOLATED THE
LOGAN ACT.
U.S. C 953.
ALL BUT RARELY FEDERAL
STATUTE PROHIBITING PRIVATE
DISPLOMS WITH FEDERAL
NATIONS.
I THINK FIVE OR SIX TIMES
IT'S BEEN USED AND MOST
INSTANCES THE PEOPLE GET OFF
INNOCENT.
SO, THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE
SUGGESTING IN THIS AND THAT
HE WAS SPEAKING, YOU KNOW,
AS PART OF THE PRESIDENT'S
INCOMING TEAM, TRANSITION
TEAM THAT THEY HAD SPOKEN TO
THE DEFENDANT, THAT HE
DENIED SPEAKING TO THE
RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR ABOUT
SANCTIONS, WHICH THE
PRESIDENT HAD ALREADY SAID
PUBLICLY IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN
THAT IN FACT, OH, THERE'S
NO -- YOU KNOW, THAT'S
PROBABLY GOING TO BE WHAT
OUR POLICY IS THAT'S IT?
THIS IS WHAT THIS IS ABOUT?
>> NO, I KNOW.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE LARGER
FRAMEWORK, OF COURSE FIRST
OF ALL IS HE A NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR.
OF COURSE IS HE GOING TO BE
TALKING TO FOREIGN DIG ANY
TEARS AND DOING THAT IN THE
TRANSITION AND YOU ARE
EXACTLY RIGHT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID EARLIER.
I KEEP TRYING TO BRING THIS
BACK INTO A CONTEXT.
THE GUY WE NEED TO TALK TO,
SEAN, WHILE THE LEFT IS
MAKING ALL KINDS OF HAY
ABOUT THIS STORY TONIGHT
ABOUT MR. FLYNN, THE GUY WE
NEED TO BE TALKING TO IS ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
IT HAS BEEN 10 AND A HALF
WEEKS SINCE IT WAS REPORTED
THAT HE TALKED TO
SUBORDINATES ABOUT WEARING A
WIRE AND INVOKING THE 25TH
AMENDMENT.
MARK AND I AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS HAVE YET TO ASK
HIM ONE SINGLE QUESTION
SINCE THAT BECAME PUBLIC.
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN THE
NEXT 26 DAYS BEFORE NANCY
PELOSI IS SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
THAT'S BLIM FOCUSED
THAT'S ILIM FOCUSED
THAT'S I'MM FOCUSED
THAT'S I'M FFOCUSED
THAT'S I'M FOCCUSED
THAT'S I'M FOCUSSED
THAT'S I'M FOCUSEDD
THAT'S I'M FOCUSED ON.
THAT'S THE THINGS WE HAVE TO
FOCUS ON IN THE LAST WEEKS
OF THIS CONGRESS.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN, IF YOU
GO BACK TO THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE REPORT COMEY
TESTIFIED THAT FBI AGENTS
SAW NO PHYSICAL INDICATIONS
OF DECEPTION.
NOW, THAT INCLUDES MCCABE.
THAT INCLUDES COMEY.
AND THAT INCLUDES PETER
STRZOK OF ALL PEOPLE THAT
INTERVIEWED HIM.
THEY DIDN'T THINK HE LIED.
AND, YOU KNOW, AND THIS
SENDS A VERY BAD MESSAGE TO
EVERYBODY.
AND THAT IS BOY, YOU BETTER
NEVER TALK TO THE FBI.
EVEN THOUGH YOU MIGHT BE
INCLINED BECAUSE HAVE YOU --
I GREW UP WITH REVERENCE FOR
THIS GREAT INSTITUTION.
YOU BETTER NEVER -- UNLESS
YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT THEN YOU
CAN SAY WHATEVER YOU WANT.
THEN YOU ARE COVERED.
THAT'S WHAT I TAKE OUT OF
IT.
>> WELL, I THINK -- IT'S NOT
JUST IN THE HOUSE INTEL.
JIM AND I HAVE BEEN PART OF
TESTIMONY AND BRIEFINGS AND
QUESTIONING WHERE THAT WAS
REITERATED NOT ONCE, NOT
TWICE, BUT THREE DIFFERENT
TIMES THAT THEY DIDN'T
BELIEVE THAT MIKE FLYNN
LIED.
SO HERE'S WHAT WE HAVE GOT.
WE HAVE GOT A SITUATION
WHERE WE ARE A YEAR AND A
HALF INTO THIS
INVESTIGATION.
IT STARTED BACK IN MAY OF
2017 AND HERE WE ARE IN
DECEMBER.
IF THIS IS THE BEST WE HAVE
GOT COMING OUT OF MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION, IT IS TIME
THAT HE WRITES THE REPORT,
CLOSES IT OUT, AND LET THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FOCUS ON
WHAT IS IMPORTANT TO THEM,
WHICH IS REALLY ABOUT MAKING
SURE THEY KEEP THEIR JOBS
AND THE ECONOMY AND WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
DELIVERING ON.
SO IT'S TIME FOR MUELLER TO
BRING IT TO A CLOSE.
HOPEFULLY THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF THE END BUT IT
CAN COME NONE TO SOON FOR
MOST AMERICANS.
>> Sean: IT'S AMAZING TO ME
JIM AS I'M READING.
THIS QUOTING "THE WASHINGTON
POST."
THEY TALK ABOUT 18 USC 957,
THAT'S THE LOGAN ACT AND
SUBSEQUENT TO -- THEY
LITERALLY QUOTE "THE
WASHINGTON POST."
AND AN ARTICLE PRIOR TO THE
DEFENDANT'S FBI INTERVIEW
MEMBERS OF PRESIDENT-ELECT'S
TRUMP TRANSITION TEAM, I
THINK THEY MIGHTEN
THINK THEY MIGHT BE TALKING
ABOUT VICE PRESIDENT PENCE
PUBLICLY SPOKEN THEY HAD
SPOKEN TO THE DEFENDANT AND
HE DENIED SPEAKING TO THE
RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR ABOUT THE
SANCTIONS.
LOOK, I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR
GUYS' LIVES IS LIKE.
I CAN TELL YOU WHAT MY LIFE
IS LIKE.
THE NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS
I HAVE ON A DAILY BASIS, IF
YOU ASK ME OHIO TALKED TO
YESTERDAY I WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO RECALL WITH ANY SENSE OF
CERTAINTY.
MOST PEOPLE LIVE BUSY LICE.
I WAS THERE, I WATCHED THIS.
THIS WAS AS BUSY AS A TIME
AS ANYTHING ELSE I'M SURE
THERE ARE A LOT OF
PLEASANTRIES BACK AND FORTH.
WE WILL WORK ON A LOT OF
ISSUES TOGETHER WHICH WOULD
SEEM PERFECTLY APPROPRIATE
TO ME.
>> IF THEY THOUGHT HE SAID
SOMETHING THAT WASN'T
ACCURATE WHY NOT CIRCLE BACK
WITH HIM.
HE SERVED OUR COUNTRY, WAS A
THREE STAR GENERAL.
WHY NOT CIRCLE BACK WITH
HIM.
AS WE POINTED OUT SELLER
TIMES, THE FBI, THESE KEY
PEOPLE, THE SAME FBI OHIO
THINK TOOK SOMETHING TO THE
FISA COURT THAT THEY DIDN'T
CHECK OUT THEMSELVES, THOSE
SAME PEOPLE SAID WE DIDN'T
THINK HE WAS MISLEADING US
AT ALL.
IF THERE WAS SOME KIND OF
QUESTION, CIRCLE BACK TO THE
GENERAL AND FIND OUT INSTEAD
OF USING IT TO GET THE
INFORMATION THAT LOOKS LIKE
MR. MUELLER WAS TRYING TO
GET.
>> ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS
THAT WE HAVE TO REALIZE JIM
AND I HAVE BEEN IN THESE
INTERVIEWS AND TESTIMONY.
THERE IS A WHOLE LOT MORE
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT IN TERMS
OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
FBI AGENTS AND PREVIOUS
AGENTS HAVE HAD THAT CALL
INTO QUESTION WHETHER THEY
ARE BEING TRUTHFUL OR NOT
THAN WHAT WE SEE WITH
GENERAL FLYNN.
AND THIS LOGAN ACT, IT'S A
RELIC OF A BY GONE ERA.
IT WAS MEANT AND DESIGNED TO
SAY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU
ARE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF A
LEGITIMATE GOVERNMENT.
IT'S TIME THAT WE LOOK AT
THIS IN A VERY DIFFERENT
LIGHT.
>> Sean: I THINK WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT IN A DIFFERENT
LIGHT.
I JUST GAVE YOU A LIST U
CHERYL MILLS, HUMA ABEDIN,
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE WHO LIED
BEFORE CONGRESS.
WE KNOW THAT THEY LIED.
THEN WE HAVE HILLARY
CLINTON.
JAMES COMEY WROTE THIS
EXONERATION IN EARLY MAY
WITH PETER STRZOK.
HE LIED AND SAID HE WASN'T
BEGINNING THE EXONERATION.
THAT'S A LIE BY HIM.
HE MIGHT HAVE ISSUES WITH
THE ESPIONAGE ACT WHEN HE
LEAKED INFORMATION TO THE
PROFESSOR FRIEND FOR THE
VERY PURPOSE OF GETTING IT
TO THE "NEW YORK TIMES" SO
THAT MIGHT SPARK THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
HE SHOULD HAVE THE SAME
LEGAL JERPDZ.
HILLARY'S MOM AND POP SHOP
BATHROOM CLOSET SERVER, WE
BELIEVE AT LEAST SIX FOREIGN
ENTITIES HACKED INTO IT WE
KNOW IT'S A VIOLATION OF THE
ESPIONAGE ACT.
WE KNOW THAT HER AIDES
EMAILED THAT VERY SITE AND
HAD EMAIL ADDRESSES FROM
THAT SITE.
I DON'T SEE ANY OF THEM
GOING THROUGH WHAT A 33 YEAR
VETERAN, FIVE YEARS OF
COMBAT VETERAN HAS GONE
THROUGH, GUY THAT SERVED HIS
COUNTRY.
DO YOU?
WHY IS THERE THIS DOUBLE
STANDARD?
>> THERE IS A DOUBLE
STANDARD IT MEANS IF YOU ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TRUMP
TEAM, THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
YOU COME UNDER GREATER
SCRUTINY THAN A LOT OF OTHER
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN HERE
AND PLAYING THE GAME HERE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
THAT MUST COME TO AN END.
IT WILL COME TO AN END.
GUYS LIKE JIM AND I ARE
WILLING TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
ENOUGH WITH THE TALK.
LET'S GET ROD ROSENSTEIN IN
HERE AND MAKE SURE THAT HE
TESTIFIES AND ACTUALLY TELLS
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT HE
SAID OR DIDN'T SAY.
>> Sean: I HAVE A TAPE.
WE PLAYED IT THE OTHER NIGHT
JIM JORDAN OF JAMES COMEY
LITERALLY SAYING WELL, I
LIE, YOU KNOW, I HAVE LIED
AND MCCABE LIED.
BUT YOU CAN STILL LIE AND BE
A GOOD PERSON.
THE EXACT WORDS OF JAMES
COMEY.
>> SEAN, JAMES COMEY WAS
SAYING HE DIDN'T WANT TO
COME TESTIFY IN A CLOSED
DOOR SESSION WITH CONGRESS
BECAUSE OF LEAKS.
THIS IS THE GUY WHO LEAKED
THE INFORMATION TO THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" TO CREATE THE
MOMENTUM FOR THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
SO, COME ON, MARK IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THERE IS TWO STANDARDS, ONE
FOR US REGULAR FOLK, A
DIFFERENT SET IF YOU ARE
PART OF THE POLITICAL